Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
leader de Public Sénat au bonheur des
livres ce soir cette émission est
particulière car nous allons la
consacrer à un seul auteur mais pas
n'importe quelle hauteur puisqu'il est
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
auteurs européens actuels et rider Luca
bonsoir bonsoir quelle présentation mais
il faut dire que c'est un grand plaisir
que vous me fassiez l'honneur de cette
conversation parce que je me souviens
très très bien lorsque j'ai découvert
votre premier livre c'était le premier
publié en France c'était une fois un
jour et c'était il y a une trentaine
d'années dans une petite maison
d'édition installée en province et issue
de l'extrême gauche les éditions Verdier
je l'ai lu je crois un peu par hasard et
depuis lors je n'ai jamais cessé de vous
lire avec attention avec plaisir et même
avec admiration alors vous écrivez
depuis toujours je crois mais vous avez
publié très tard pour des raisons qu'on
va qu'on va évoquer tout à l'heure
depuis lors vous êtes bien rattrapé par
ce que aucun genre littéraire n'échappe
ne vous est étranger Vous écrivez des
romans vous écrivez des récits vous
écrivez des essais vous écrivez des
poèmes vous écrivez des pièces de
théâtre vous écrivez des nouvelles et ce
sont des bijoux
aucun ne vous est étrangers et vos
textes en général sont courts et ils
sont comme vous et filets comme des
épées mais ils sont nombreux
et les éditions la collection quarto
chez Gallimard a eu l'excellente idée
d'en publier une partie seulement
1000 pages mais une partie seulement et
je dois dire que c'est extrêmement
agréable de pouvoir se promener de
manière gourmette dans des oeuvres qu'on
connaît déjà ou de découvrir des textes
qu'on ne connaissait pas par exemple
j'ai découvert que vous aviez écrit des
pièces de théâtre en napolitain
la caractéristique de votre écriture
c'est le lien intrinsèque entre votre
existence d'ailleurs romanesque et vos
livres vos livres ont très souvent une
résonance autobiographique même si
évidemment le travail littéraire
transforme ce matériau existentiel et
donc je me suis dit qu'une des façons de
dans la demi-heure que nous avons de
traverser cette oeuvre c'est de
traverser votre vie d'essayer de faire
ça par de franchir les étapes de votre
vie en même temps de vous de vos livres
donc vous êtes d'abord né en 1950 1950
c'est juste après la guerre et la guerre
joue dans votre œuvre un rôle
considérable les bombardements et votre
famille dans les abris l'insurrection de
43 par laquelle Naples se libère du
nazisme mais aussi la persécution des
Juifs qui est un fil conducteur de la
lecture de votre ouvrage est-ce qu'on
peut dire que la guerre et l'événement
tragique qui est la matrice qui est la
source de votre vocation d'écrivain et
de votre œuvre
mais la guerre de 20e siècle la guerre
moderne qui se qui est différente de
toutes les autres guerres du passé parce
que visent plutôt à tous les décisives
que des soldats ça c'est son produit
lourd
plus de maître de civils que de soldats
donc c'est une guerre qui a cherché la
vie des personnes directement chez eux
des vêtements dans les maisons et donc
c'est une guerre criminelle par
excellence
et a rendu protagoniste héroïque et
survivant les
membres les membres des familles donc
c'est pour ça que cette guerre c'est
épénétré dans mon
éducation sentimentale j'ai commencé à
réagir aux histoires que j'écoutais de
la
première moitié du siècle les histoires
qui étaient dit à napolitaine par des
voies des femmes napolitaines et que
cette force curieuse de pénétrer dans
mon système nerveux et me rendre
physiquement dans ce que je pouvais être
à côté de à côté de ces femmes tant que
la modulation des fréquences de l'air de
les voir qui n'étaient pas toujours
fragiles ils avaient besoin de comique
aussi ça c'est une chose que
avoir le ridicule avec le tragique mais
c'était indispensable c'était une
formule indispensable pour poursuivre le
récit et avoir encore envie de parler
c'est très lié d'ailleurs un deuxième
élément de votre biographie je dis que
vous êtes né en 1950 mais vous êtes né à
Naples et Naples et probablement le
personnage principal de vos livres un
Naples évidemment qui est compliqué mais
qui est toujours pris entre deux feux
donc on a le sentiment que vous voulez
fuir Naples mais qu'en même temps vous
ne pouvez jamais vous en détacher quel
est comme une mère au sens de maman une
mère envahissante qui est à la fois dans
ton est très proche et dont on veut
absolument à laquelle on veut absolument
échapper
d'abord c'est une ville que dans le 20e
siècle a vu partir millions de personnes
à travers les lignes de navigation de la
White Starline en napolitaine waste qui
faisait le kiki amené des millions
d'Italiens vers les Amériques
et puis c'est 1000 qui dépend de la
ombre d'un grand volcan catastrophique
donc c'est une ville qui a
[Musique]
pris mes m'a formé mon caractère
encore mes sentiments de compassion de
colère de honte ce sont formés à Naples
donc je peux dire je l'ai quitté cette
ville je pouvais plus être là-dedans
mais je suis entièrement napolitaine ça
veut dire que cette ville pour moi n'a
pas été une ville maire mais une ville
cause et je suis un de ses effets ce
sont
perdure en terme belle formule alors
votre enfant se déroule à Naples elle se
déroule dans le quartier que vous avez
notamment décrit dans montée des diots
qui est le roman peut-être le plus connu
de vous en France parce qu'il a reçu le
féminin étranger donc c'est un quartier
des ruelles populaires mais votre
famille
issue de la bourgeoisie en fait a été
ruiné par la guerre déclassé socialement
et elle est un peu à part dans ce
quartier mais l'enfant que vous décrivez
soit dans les récits soit parfois dans
des romans et souvent un enfant enfermé
dans lui-même boiteux Bègue dont les
mets dans les meilleures compagnons sont
les livres notamment les livres de votre
père et je l'autre jour j'écoutais
Malraux avait dit André Malraux avait
dit à François Mauriat qui a deux types
d'écrivains il y a les écrivains qui
adorent leur enfance qui sont enfermés
dans leur enfance ça c'est Mauriac et il
y a les écrivains qui détestent leur
enfance et toute leur œuvre est faite
contre leur enfance ça c'est malheureux
alors vous vous situez où vous êtes
plutôt
Mauriac l'amour de l'enfance du paradis
de l'enfance ou Malraux la détestation
de l'enfance je considère la France une
image immense
ça veut dire que dans l'enfance on
contient toutes les possibilités de la
vie future donc c'est un
possible
divagations que de la vie sont renfermés
dans l'enfance c'est comme on se trouve
en bas d'une paroi non pour rejoindre le
chemin on peut prendre n'importe quelle
quelle ligne de monter mais comme dans
l'âge comme on passe le temps les lignes
vont se réduire jusqu'à une on devient à
la fin une selle des toutes les
possibilités écartées pendant le
parcours et alors l'enfance pour moi
c'est l'immensité et c'est pour ça que
je
vais mettre à l'écoute de mon enfance
maintenant j'ai les mots pour le dire
alors à l'époque j'avais pas les mots
mais je vais tous les sentiments et
toutes les possibilités de
ma vie future et au moment de
l'adolescence les possibles se referment
un peu dans dans votre œuvre il y a un
roman d'app apprentissage notamment dans
l'île d'iska qui est l'une des îles de
la mer tirerénéenne en phase de Naples
dans lequel vous vos narrateur vos
personnages
découvrent enfin rentrent
progressivement dans l'âge adulte et là
c'est aussi une expérience
contrastée on a l'impression que
l'adolescence n'a jamais été insouciante
que dès le départ le souci et là que dès
le départ le sentiment de la
responsabilité habite l'adolescent que
vous décrivez oui ben ça c'est la faute
à ma mère aussi la responsabilité de ma
mère parce que
on habitait dans le quartier populaire
et les gens qui avaient mon âge les
enfants qui avaient mon âge allaient
travailler ou plutôt avait la plus haute
mortalité enfantine d'Europe et ma mère
toujours me faisait
noter les différences et non privilèges
on privilège d'avoir une nourriture des
chaussures de la de l'éducation de la de
la cour verticale mais ça ne me donnait
pas un sentiment de
culpabilité
ce sentiment n'est jamais c'est jamais
produit de moi le sens de culpabilité je
l'ignore complètement mais par contre
mais responsable je devais répondre donc
quelques manières ma part elle mais je
devais répondre à moi à tout ce que à
toutes ces inégalités toutes ces
différences de conditions de la vie et
donc
la voix de ma mère m'a transformé dans
quelqu'un qui à l'aveugle va essayer de
répondre à la pression des événements
autour
on va voir comment ça se traduit parce
qu'on se
cet appel de la justice en vous en 1968
vous quittez là vous allez à Rome et là
vous entrez dans l'âge d'homme mais en
même temps vous entrez dans la rébellion
étudiante dans l'extrême gauche vous
allez devenir l'un des dirigeants d'une
d'organisation qui s'appelle l'OTA
continua et il faut préciser à ceux qui
nous écoutent que le mouvement de 68 en
Italie en Allemagne aussi d'ailleurs
peut-être pour des raisons semblables a
eu une dimension particulière d'abord il
a été beaucoup plus long par que par
tout ailleurs il a duré 10 ans ensuite
il y avait une alliance au moins au
début entre la classe ouvrière et le
mouvement étudiant et enfin dernièrement
ce mouvement a basculé dans la violence
et quand on vous lit on a l'impression
que vous avez par rapport à ce moment
charnière central décisif pour vous
désormais un rapport double d'un côté la
fidélité la fidélité à l'élan de justice
de ce mouvement mais d'un autre côté
l'homme que vous êtes devenu porte un
jugement moral sur la tentation de la
violence et le basculement de la
violence
je peux pas extraire la violence de
l'histoire du 20e siècle nous avons été
la dernière génération révolutionnaire
d'un siècle révolutionnaire c'est comme
ça que c'est réalisé la transformation
de la géographie politique humaine du
20e siècle à travers les révolutions
qui ont fait
tomber des empires colonial donc on
donnait vie à des nouvelles nations à de
la liberté et à l'indépendance de peuple
nouveau donc ce format de la politique
de la révolution c'est
traîner jusqu'à à ma génération nous
étions contemporain d'une jeunesse
révolutionnaire autour du monde du
Vietnam à l'Amérique du Sud à travers
l'Afrique et comme ça donc il y avait ce
ordre du jour du monde auquel nous avons
obéi
ordre du jour du monde qui entraînait
la violence la nécessité la nécessité de
se défendre aussi de la violence parce
que nous avons été en Italie la
génération la plus emprisonnée pour des
motifs pour des raisons politiques de
l'histoire italienne donc ça a été une
nous avons eu à quoi faire avec une
répression qui était massive
et c'est pour ça et qui se produit à qui
produit encore des
poursuites pénales encore aujourd'hui
depuis presque 50 ans donc
la violence a été présente dans la dans
le 20e siècle
j'en ai fait partie oui mais j'ai
l'impression je me trompe peut-être que
c'est une erreur d'interprétation j'ai
l'impression disons que lorsque vous
étiez jeune homme vous auriez pu être
proche de la conception de Sartre de
l'engagement mais que l'adulte que vous
êtes devenu l'homme mûr que vous êtes
devenu et plutôt plus proche de de la
conception de Camus de la responsabilité
vos personnages vous vous narrateurs on
a le sentiment qu'ils sont poursuivis
par leurs actes et que rien ne peut
effacer les fautes qu'on a commises
il y a c'est pas c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que vous n'êtes pas
catholique c'est parce que vous
n'acceptez ni le pardon ni l'absolution
il y a une un caractère inexpiable de la
responsabilité est-ce que ça n'est pas
une c'est une morale extraordinairement
rigoureuse
c'est quelque chose de naturel qui est
bien moi d'abord je suis toujours été du
côté Camille
oui mais quand j'ai pris des engagements
c'était parce que ils avaient pris les
autres ma génération avait pris des
engagements ma génération tout entière
avait décidé de descendre du trottoir et
marcher dans le centre de la rue et
cette petite descente du trottoir fait
entrer des vies privées dans une voie
publique et on vit public entre dans
l'histoire descendante
avec toute une communauté donc c'est
j'ai adhéré à la à la aujourd'hui du
jour de ma génération par contre à
l'intellectuel comme Camus il agit en
tant que lui en tant que seul en tant
qu'individu je suis devenu individu
malgré moi ça veut dire parce que cette
communauté révolutionnaire fraternelle
dans lequel j'ai donné toute ma toute ma
jeunesse c'est dissouze et alors je suis
devenu un individu
d'abord ouvrir parce que j'ai fait
presque 20 ans de vie ouvrier de lui
ouvrir
après individu aussi comme écrivain et
donc engagement je suis
un équival engagé je suis un écrivant
qui écrit ces histoires mais comme
citoyen j'ai des engagements je vous
poursuivez vos engagements on le voit
mais ils ont quand même changé de nature
et je me demande aussi si le goût que
vous avez développé pour l'Ancien
Testament la présence du monde juif en
vous la priantissage de l'hébreu la
lecture de la Bible est-ce que ce qui
vous fascine dans la Bible c'est aussi
parce que
l'apparition du judaïsme c'est
l'apparition de la religion de la loi
morale donc est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi
dans la lecture dans laquelle vous êtes
entré à peu près à l'âge d'homme et dans
votre rapport au judaïsme cette question
qui vous hante de la responsabilité
morale où je me trompe
ce qui
m'a fait approcher à la à l'ancien
groupe a été la le fait que cette
divinité manifeste sa manif se manifeste
avec les mots aucune autre divinité
avait fait ce choix de se révéler à
travers les mots bayom et il dit et il
dit il dit et le verbe plus accroché au
sujet divinité de toute l'Ancien
Testament il dit cette manifestation
physique
et sur les mots qui ne servent pas
seulement à kumonoker sont des mots qui
arrivent à créer
inventer le monde tous les six jours de
la création sont précédés par la il dit
après qu'il dit la chose se produit se
produit la création après qu'il dit la
lumière soit il y a la lumière s'il ne
dit pas la lumière il n'y a pas de
lumière sont ces mots que sont les
créateurs et aussi les responsables
directs de la de la chose de la chose
crée et donc cette
identité cette loyauté entre les mots et
l'action et ce qui m'a
amené vers l'ancien on sent en tout cas
dans vos livres que le fait d'être
ouvrier à une dimension particulière ça
n'est pas comme les maoïstes qui se sont
établies pour utiliser le mot pour
expier leur origine bourgeoise ou pour
évangéliser les masses il y a quand on
vous lit le sentiment que la condition
ouvrière est une espèce de manifestation
presque pure de la condition humaine de
ce qu'il y a d'humain dans l'homme
beaucoup dire c'est beau dire comme ça
mais pour moi
[Musique]
en effet collatéral
le travail était indispensable
nécessaire
me permettait de gagner ma vie qui a été
une vie très économique parce que j'ai
pas de famille donc j'ai pas
bébé à faire grandir à l'école donc
je travaille aujourd'hui
pour moi et
ce qui a
transmis est plutôt une discipline une
discipline physique une régularité
physique qui m'aide encore toujours que
j'ai terminé de travailler de
physiquement depuis des décennies non
mais
encore
règlement mes horaires de la journée et
mon emploi de la énergie physique Macron
encore quelque chose
j'allais vous le dire j'espère que vous
avez pas le prendre mal mais
votre sentiment de la responsabilité
votre altruisme
c'est à 16 votre votre vie ascétique on
voit d'ailleurs comme vous êtes se lever
tôt escalader les montagnes se nourrir
peu
on dirait vous êtes presque ne le prenez
pas mal comme un curé mais un curé qui
ne croirait pas en Dieu et qui n'aurait
pas fait le vœu de chasteté oui
j'ai pas fait des veaux
je prends je me suis trouvé bien comme
ça
dans l'expérience de l'expériment
d'ailleurs vieillir c'est une activité
très expérimentale ça veut dire que
personne abandonne-nous peut nous
apprendre comme vieillir c'est une
expérience individuelle et où on se
débrouille en en battant des en
cherchant des solutions des
expérimentant des choses physiques sur
soi
aller en montagne est grimper c'est une
activité qui m'aide à vieillir mieux
ce sont des choses qui me prend pour
pour
la veste et alors il me force à répondre
ça me frappait énormément c'est que vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est que vous
êtes considérés comme l'écrivain de
l'épopée 68 non pas du tout des
événements de 68 mais l'écrivain qui
retrace le mieux ce qui s'est passé dans
la tête de cette génération comment elle
a été frappée des fautes de la
génération précédente notamment le
nazisme fascisme comment elle a essayé
de de de
[Musique]
d'agir pour compenser ses fautes et
comment elle-même parfois a fait des
erreurs donc vous êtes l'écrivain de
cette génération et en même temps votre
oeuvre vous l'avez dit n'est pas du tout
une œuvre sociale vous n'êtes pas les
1000 Zola ou le Balzac d'aujourd'hui
c'est une œuvre c'est vous vous
traversez votre vos histoires et c'est
d'ailleurs une écriture souvent très
lapidaire parfois un peu peut-être à
cause de la lecture de la Bible parfois
un peu
oraculaire enfin qui est inspiré de la
Bible mais c'est pas du tout la grande
fresque sociale c'est le il y a une
écriture aussi assez tique elle-même
acétique de cette de soi
oui parce que je pense que dès que les
histoires que j'ai écrit sur des
histoires qui regardent ma vie
ça veut dire que l'eau de la vie va
pouvoir rester du sel un président et
c'est ça
que c'est sec et c'est
étroit c'est court c'est
une réduction en format réducteur réduit
de la de l'expérience de la vie et les
mots arrivent à boire cette arrogance de
dire
donner le format définitif à cette
expérience et en même temps
il y a forcément une aporie une impasse
enfin vous votez que sont éblouissants
pour moi et donc vous arrivez à faire
toucher malgré cette écriture désertique
fin de sable vous arrivez à faire
toucher du doigt l'expérience que vous
avez vécue les questions morales qu'elle
pose mais en même temps est-ce qu'il y a
pas dans le dans le dans le dans la vie
d'un écrivain la frustration que vous ne
pourrez jamais
représenter vraiment cette histoire
qu'elle va forcément s'échapper
forcément
se réduire comme vous le dites vous
pouvez écrire et écrire et écrire encore
sans jamais arriver à saisir le réel où
vous continuez à avoir cette espérance
non non non l'expérience de que j'ai
comme lecteur je me je m'arrête pas à en
écrivain pour savoir quelque chose il
doit dire beaucoup de crimes
beaucoup de témoignages en ne suffit pas
et donc je suis un comme le climat qui
ne suffit pas
mais qui peut être un des
passages pour arriver à encadrer une
époque c'est une époque dès que ce 20e
siècle
héritier contre les vies privées et les
vies personnelles alors quelle est la
forme le format historique le cinéma le
cinéma qui dit les histoires des
particuliers des personnes le plus grand
historique du 20e siècle pour moi
et pour chaque retour est la même chose
il y a des petites vies écrasées par la
grande histoire du 20e siècle qui ont
cette expérience extraordinaire
extraordinaire de la narrative
presque légendaire seront
éliminés survécu
et heureusement il y a des écrivains
comme vous pour saisir cela et pour nous
le restituer malheureusement notre
conversation va s'arrêter j'aurais bien
aimé qu'on continue encore mais bon
avant que nous ne nous quittions Éric je
voudrais que vous nous recommandiez on
va recommander des livres pour nos ceux
qui nous ont écouté et je voudrais vous
demander quel est le livre que vous avez
lu récemment dernièrement et qui que
vous auriez envie que nos lecteurs
lisent que nos auditeurs lisent pardon
c'est un Bible en français
je sais que je vous dérange en paix avec
cette maximum mon choix parce que c'est
le livre de Violetta d'ourson
même le bruit de la nuit a changé c'est
un livre admis italienne
richesse de l'Autriche sur les classes
de son père qu'elle a perdu très jeune
donc elle ne l'a jamais connu et il va
le rechercher dans le souvenir des
autres et ce passage à travers le
souvenir de ce produit en Italie rend en
format
monumental de ce père
rechercher avec cet amour et cette
acharnement et j'ai que je suis pas père
le sentiment à travers la lecture de ce
livre d'avoir complètement raté la
possibilité d'avoir un amour filial qui
me cherche comme ça vous me gênez parce
que j'ai un lien avec elle et d'ailleurs
je ne savais pas que vous alliez
défendre ce livre mais vous me ravissez
parce que j'aime beaucoup cette
écrivaine et j'adore le livre qu'elle a
écrit nous comme c'est la Semaine
italienne de la du festival du livre et
que vous êtes notre invité on a choisi
des livres en prenant un risque énorme
que vous n'ayez aucun ces livres mais
c'est pas grave vous allez faire comme
si donc il y a dans les éditions
bouquins une 3 3 une série de textes
d'Alberto Moravia qui est considéré je
ne pose pas la question à Eri de ce
qu'il en pense qui est considéré comme
un grand écrivain italien notamment le
l'écrivain des relations amoureuses et
de la description sociale
des lettres ce sont des lettres de
Pierre Paolo Pasolini ce sont des
lettres que des anonymes ont écrit
auquel il a répondu c'est un dialogue
avec l'opinion ital
ça c'est un auteur de roman policier
Carlo Lucarelli péché mortel un grand
auteur de roman policier je crois
qu'héry ne lit jamais de romans policier
mais il a une particularité c'est que
son commissaire s'appelle des Lucas
probablement inspiré par Eric c'est
peut-être un clin d'œil et puis enfin je
crois Kery ne lit pas non plus de bande
dessinée Manara c'est le grand maître de
la du de la bande dessinée érotique et
c'est un
précisé qui n'est pas fait le vœu de
chasteté un grand maître de la de la
bande dessinée érotique et c'est un
grand maître italien c'est probablement
le plus grand auteur de bande dessinée
italienne voilà nos choix de cette
semaine cette émission s'achève merci
infiniment et rider Luca d'avoir bien
voulu participer à cette émission donc
je rappelle quarto une anthologie de
certains de vos textes et puis on publie
aussi grandeur nature chez Gallimard ce
sont des récits remarquables donc merci
infiniment de cette conversation merci
en général des livres que vous publiez
et qui nous ravissent
vous pouvez revoir cette émission sur le
site de Public Sénat ou sur votre
plateforme préférée et sinon nous nous
retrouvons la semaine prochaine à la
même heure à moins que d'ici là nous ne
nous soyons rencontrés dans une
librairie merci et bonsoir
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres